hi there I'm an oppressor Robinson for
gamespot here at e3 2014 in the Ubisoft
booth with Leslie who is a producer for
Assassin's Creed unity how are you doing
so far today Leslie it's great i'm
really excited to 83 so we've seen a lot
of really exciting things about the new
assassin's creed but let's start at the
beginning where is this assassins creed
going to be set what are we going to
experience so this assassins creed takes
place in the city of paris during the
french revolution it looks pretty
intense yeah and it's it's amazing
because it's such a really chaotic time
period so it's perfect for an assassin's
creed game yeah and I've seen a lot of
you know it's all about the the group
play right I've seen I've seen this
multiplayer thing rolled out and kind of
cooperating we see a city at war with
itself so it's kind of an appropriate
time it seems like to bring out that
multiplayer can you tell me about how
that's going to roll out for the players
so you can play with up to four friends
and it's all seamless within the city of
Paris so you can play actually the
single-player story as well as the
multiplayer all within the city of Paris
and you can play with up to four friends
and the idea is the idea is to focus on
communication and strategy and
synchronization and we've revamped our
game players so our three game pillars
is navigation combat and stealth and
what we've done is we've given a lot
more player choice so now when you're
playing with friends you're playing as a
team you can kind of play to your own
game style and complement each other I
see so I could strategize if I want to
play a certain play style i want to
bring my friend and who's going to play
a different play style and so forth yeah
exactly you know some people like to be
leaders some people like to sort of you
more the planning in the background with
our new stealth to you can infiltrate
and sort of like you know tell your
friends and the tell your friends behind
you saying hey don't go down this
corridor find another way and you see
that a lot in our co-op demo as well
that we thought online very cool you
know as we look at Assassin's Creed this
is a long and storied well-loved
franchise you know a lot of these these
stories have been treasured throughout
the years looking at this Assassin's
Creed what are we going to see that
reminds us of our Assassin's Creed roots
and what are we going to see that's all
brand-new well I think the biggest thing
is of course we're going back to an
urban setting you know we're going back
to
the beautiful city of Paris and it's the
perfect place to showcase our new
navigation I mentioned before we got
more freedom for the players we got a
lot more precision too so now instead of
you know sort of just free running and
the path of the other that base and
takes is sort of like predefined for you
in a little way now you can decide if
you want to go up or go down go through
buildings giving a lot more player
choice and so going back to the roots
going back to an urban setting has
really been great for that great so walk
me through I sit down I play the game
maybe I'm playing single player how do I
get involved with a multiplayer can I
bring someone in right then do I play
from the very beginning with my friends
how does that work I mentioned earlier
that it was really seamless with the
world so the idea is do you know you
could be wandering around the city and
then you can go into a tavern and your
friends that are online you can find
them in the tavern and you know you can
go up to them and see that you know hey
maybe they're playing a brotherhood
mission which is what we're calling our
co-op missions and at that moment you
could just like join their mission in
progress and play with them I'm seeing
the co-op multiplayer decision being
made by a lot of games here at e3 why
was that something that was important
for you to integrate into assassins
creed it's actually one of our most
requested features by our fans so and we
had to find the right opportunity to
bring that feature into the world with
next-gen it was a great chance to sort
of like start from scratch so we rebuilt
our engines specifically for next-gen
and that allowed us to rewrite
everything to support online co-op
Assassin's Creed's also a really pretty
game so speaking of next-gen are we
going to see some really stunning
graphics here too absolutely we have a
brand new rendering engine we've got
physically based rendering we've got
global illumination we've have a whole
host of beautiful features to really
make the game look amazing great so you
know the person who's played assassin's
creed before probably going to want to
check this out but in general what kind
of gamers really going to enjoy this
this iteration of assassin's creed um I
think for sure people who who want to
work as a team if you really value what
it is to not always be the the one and
only hero to really you know find ways
where you can be smart as a group and I
think that that's really going to stand
out a lot in this assassins creed well
that describes me so I'll be sure to
check it out thank you so much for your
time Leslie thank you very much are you
gonna check out Assassin's Creed unity
let me know
by tweeting at an oppressor with the
hashtag gamespot III